good morning everyone can you hear me
yeah so thanks for coming and a Sunday
morning it's a 9:00 a.m. I really
appreciate so my talk is about learning
programming in science with scientific
bison I should have written actually how
I learned programming and science with
scientific Python because it's kind of a
personal journey I will start with a big
thank you to the organizers of the
confluence so big thank you from the
psychic family because so thanks to the
child care that you provide we were able
to come as a family so you can see the
rest of the family a little there so
there's a psychic loneguy sacred image
girl in the psychic baby and I have to
say it really makes a difference when
you have to decide whether you go to a
conference and you don't have to choose
between spending time with your family
and learning cool things with cool
people about PI data so I hope this kind
of initiatives will continue in that
other conferences will also have child
care so let's have a big round of
applause for the organizers who
[Applause]
so as mark already introduced me I am a
researcher so working in material
science I study glass I like to do
experiments in big x-ray facilities
synchrotrons I'm also team manager I'm
the director of a lab was about 25
people so you see this a smiling team
here and on my spare time I'm a core
developer of the cycads image image
processing package and so he was a the
synchrotron where I like to do
experiments so it's a big big experiment
with lots of cables so you feel you're
doing really science when you go there
and what I like to do is look at
materials from the inside to understand
for example if we can save energy when
we melt glass at very high temperature
so here you have a movie with the raw
materials of glass so sand and
carbonates and I try to understand from
this quite complicated 3d images the
reactions the chemical reactions and if
we can improve industrial processes so
this is basically my research and it
requires to interpret you segment to
analyze this images which are full of
artifacts which are really large too and
so the kind of problems that I have many
fold first I have scientific and
development problems I need to find
series of image processing operations
that will allow me to extract the
scientific information I'm interested in
I also need to run this operations and
very large data sets I'm talking about
several terabytes of data for one
experiment because it's sweidy imaging
tomography and hopefully in reasonable
time and of course as a developer
I once I get image to strive I wanted to
be rid of bugs etc so these are my
really technical problems but I also
have other problems that are sometimes
more challenging which are related to
social and learning problems because in
my team I'm working with quite junior
people who arrive in the lab and they
have little experience in programming
and image processing and so I need to
help them to learn both sides of the
problem programming and image processing
and of course I'm also interested in
having more developers and users of
circuit image so this is this second
part which I'm going to focus on during
my talk that is how how our tools are
great in order to empower people to
learn fast well what is specific neural
tools which make learning easy and of
course what could be also improved so
I'll start with a little introduction to
psych it image what can be done with it
and then I move on to this learning part
starting with simplicity the API and
then focusing a lot of documentation and
how can we make documentation more
interactive and if I have time I'll end
with a few challenges for the future
what is image parsing the definition is
a bit fuzzy it's really manifold but you
can summarize it at the manipulations of
images to transform other images for
other purposes like you you want it to
look better you want to enhance contrast
and so on and you want to extract
information from these images in science
you want to do that quite often and so
here I have put a few common tasks that
you want to do with image processing for
example filtering
low contrast noisy images future
extraction for further machine learning
segmentation of some regions - so you
want to label the pixels to extract
objects and when you have extracted
objects usually you want to measure
things on these objects to do some
science so in this crowd well when you
come to a very nice conference like PI
data and you hear all these talks about
deep learning machine learning
especially deep learning you might think
is a future to traditional image
processing because it isn't deep
learning the universal solution to all
image processing problems and indeed
some a lot of image processing tasks can
be done and are done using deep learning
I have put two examples here image
classification that this image was taken
from the chaos blocks where you want to
identify all the cats pictures so I have
a slide with cats picture and also image
segmentation for example here you want
to label pixels belonging to the person
and to the background and this was done
with fully control convolutional
networks so you can do this quite
efficiently with deep learning so do you
really need this sequence of filtering
extraction segmentation and so on that
you do in traditional image processing I
think there is room for other tools then
deep learning in the field of image
processing one reason is that a lot of
people have images that are not natural
images here is an example from biology
where you have cells that have a
specific configuration and you will not
have a very large database that you can
use as a learning set and it's the same
for this image that comes from a
simulation so it's not even an image
that was taken with a sensor it's a
result that's and then grid with some
scholars on it
and
here is another example from a colleague
from my lab she gave it to me yesterday
and so she wants to extract all these
little grains and this images are quite
specific so it's quite hard to say oh I
will take this very big training set and
do the deep learning on it another
reason to use two additional image
processing is to avoid what I would call
the sledgehammer approach because
sometimes you want to do simple
operations like contrast enhancement
histogram equalization when we look at
papers which cites our circuit image
paper sometimes they just use one
function in the paper in the cycads and
so sometimes you need to do very simple
things and deep learning is of course
quite costly and traditional image
processing can also be used as a
pre-processing for machine learning I
will have a few examples about this so
what is Sai kit image in a few words so
who here has already used psychedelic
just to have an IDE okay so who didn't
know about the package before coming
here yeah okay great
so it's a no point source image
processing live where we so it's not an
application it's a really a live movie
that you can import in your own packages
it's for baton works brilliantly with an
empire waist and it works for 2d but
sweetie images as well which is a
specificity of psychic image other tools
work only for 2d images and we strive to
have a simple API and quite a gentle
learning curve I will insist on this
point here are some examples of what
circuit image can do for segmentation
here so segmentation is the labeling of
pixels belonging to different kinds of
objects and for a given task we usually
have a variety of functions that do
different things so so depending on your
application your image you can choose
one of them for example here
segmentation
and special doing super pixels
segmentation which is an automatic
segmentation region grows with a
watershed or control based segmentation
so it's a bit like cookbook you have all
your ingredients and after you need to
make them together here in the PI data
confluence you might be interested in
the possibilities for extracting
features out of images so features can
be points of interest in images like
corners for example or you can also
extract texture feature
like cable filter kernels and so on and
I have an example here from my research
where I have this so it's a gypsum grain
it's what you use in plaster boards and
we're looking at the reaction
dehydration reaction where here you have
a dehydration front and I wanted to
segment the reacted non reacted part so
I just use these pixels and these pixels
as a training set computing Daisy
features from the future sub module of
psychic image and after I uses random
forest classifier of scikit-learn so you
have to know that psychic image and
scikit-learn interact really well
together because they both used in
umpire ways and I used the probability
vector of the classifier as an image to
segment so going back to image
processing using some filtering of this
probability map because it had some
holes special doing and mathematical
morphology so I'm not giving many
details about the approach it's just
realist rates at Sagat image and
scikit-learn work really well together
and that you can use machine learning to
do image segmentation here so the
package is quite popular now when we
look at visit statistics on the circuit
image dot org website we have more than
20,000 you
visitors per month and if we look at
this typical users it's interesting to
see that maybe typical users are not the
same as a typical PI data attendee for
example I'm not sure that there are 54%
of Windows computers here I have nothing
against windows it's just the statistics
might be different here and also when
you look at the typical time of a visit
it's quite short so it means that people
are looking for information but they
might not find it immediately and so
they leave the website and so half half
of the visits are very short so the
take-home message here is that the
typical users are not hardcore geeks
they need to learn things and they don't
have a lot of time to spend reading
documentation and of course learning and
finding information is hard for them so
that's for users for developers we have
a core team of about 10 people and so
this is quite a busy graph but it
represents so the percentage of commits
weights normalized by the largest
contributor and decrease with the number
of commuters so in order to understand
this graph you have to understand that
for example this person contributed 40%
as much of pull requests as of of
commits as the largest contributor so
the largest the the faster the decay the
less contributors core contributors you
have let's say and I'm glad that you
seem to have understood it because it's
a big one and so socket image is
here in light blue scikit-learn here so
you see that scikit-learn has a very
healthy development curve according to
this graph and so it's a keyed image
it's a it's quite good so that's why I
say that we have between five and ten
core contributors and contributors but
it's always a lot of efforts to include
new people and to make them confident
enough to become first contributors and
then maintain as possible so I will now
start with the the focus of my talk how
can we empower people and make sure that
they learn fast because as we saw there
are some developers but not a lot and a
lot of users a lot of them being
beginners so we want them to learn
things fast and one first thing to do is
resisting complexity as a developer it's
very tempting often to build very
beautiful cathedrals and things which
can be quite complicated and will
confuse your users so how can we avoid
confusing users I'll start with this
quote from the regreted Peter Hinton's
good software solves useful problems in
a simple way and I think this in a
simple way is very important and I would
like to go back 15 years ago when I
first started programming just to to
share with you what I saw at the moment
when I started programming programming
really faith it felt like magic for me
because I was walking with a postdoc in
the lab in a hydrodynamic slab and he
was giving me some MATLAB commands and
so there were really like magical spells
I didn't know if I had to execute all of
them in the same order if the order
would change something I had never had
any programming class and
it felt really difficult because it was
just some some magics and of course you
might think okay why are you talking
about learning to program now most
people have classes about programming
here in this room we all know how to
program okay but if we try to to take a
beginners shoes then we can understand
better why it is difficult to learn new
abstractions because mastering new
abstractions is really what increases
the cognitive load when you learning
things so for a python beginner
here are some abstractions that she
needs to master what is viable
what is a path what is assigning by
viable control flow what is that a for
loop okay I might understand it but it's
still in abstraction to master and now
when you go through data scientists
which who have more experience they also
have abstractions to master like what is
an estimator what is segmentation what
is the structuring element in
mathematical morphology and so on and if
we can reduce the number of abstractions
that we impose on the user then the
learning curve will be much faster so
one way of reducing the number of
abstractions is to share some
abstractions between tools and
fortunately for this we have the numpy
away which is great shared abstraction
for numerical arrays and of course we
all know Empire ways but when I started
programming actually we didn't have yet
no bite we had numeric and so there were
several tools which could be used and so
now numpy is great because it has a lot
of features for example that we found
for indexing slicing but it's also very
simple and that's why it's a really good
abstractions to use for an image because
if you have a 2d nampeya way it can be
considered as a
image pixels being just away elements so
here is an example of black and white
away and if you want to have a color
image then you just need three colour
channels for r g and b and at the same
for a 3d image you like my tomography
images you can have a 3d away and so
using this number ways
Sackett image works with number ways
both as arguments like for this Gaussian
filter here and as output here my
filtered away is an empire way so cycle
image is meant to walk very
transparently wisdom byways it didn't
used to be this way because when we
started cycle image when you asked was a
type of the output of circuit image
function then it was an image object so
at the moment at this moment we thought
yeah objects are images so it makes
sense to call them an image class and so
it's really great people will know that
it is an image and we also can have some
specific attributes like maybe the the
name of the file of the image or the
dimensions and so on turns out it was
really confusing users because for
example when we asked for the max of
something that was just in a way it was
not a scholar it was also an image
object so it really made users confused
and so we just ditched it and now we
have no highways and so people just need
to know that images and byways one thing
that makes the API quite simple is also
that it's the same API for both 2d and
3d images so here you have an example of
the label function labeling connected
components both in a 2d and a 3d image
it's exactly the same syntax makes
things easier
and we enabled this using some little
tricks like using the NP dot at least 3d
function so that you can manipulate
transparently 3d images as if they were
3d images so it makes also the code
codebase really easier and simpler so as
you see on the signature here of this
quick shift filter one when filter is
just one function and the first argument
is usually and it's always an image in
circuit image and then you have keyword
arguments for parameter tuning and we
have such signatures in a very
consistent way which also makes things
easier for users so the IP I of psychic
image is that we have sub modules and
inside the sub modules mostly functions
which take an umpire Airways as input
and output is also an empire ways so we
had a lot of discussions whether we
should have sub modules or not for
example some developers we're in favor
of having all the functions under the
big umbrella of psyche team H it was
quite a controversy but the reason why
we chose sub modules is that if you're
looking for a specific function and you
know what it should do it might be
easier to look for example for denoising
filter in west ovation or for
segmentation algorithms in segmentation
we have mostly functions but we still
have a one or two classes for example
here this minimum cost pass function
which is mostly used for internally for
other functions but we also expose it in
the API and actually when I looked at
the website statistics this page is
almost never visited meaning that people
really prefer using the functions and
just a few words about object-oriented
programming from time to time I have a
colleague popping in my office and
saying I have this new way of processing
my images I think I will make a class
and I say stop do you really need to
make a class because object-oriented
programming is really okay for
abstractions that are easy like when you
look at examples on the web of
object-oriented programming you have a
lot of them using a person class and
well a person is usually an abstraction
that's your familiar to at least you
sure you should be and other
abstractions are like geometric cool
objects like points something that you
learned at school so that it's really
abstraction that you share but a minimum
cost path you don't really know what it
is from the first start in terms of
mathematics so do you really need to
make it a class it's it's not obvious of
course I'm not saying that
object-oriented programming is not good
because when you have a very simple and
consistent API like what scikit-learn
does where you have this estimators who
all have this fit and this predict
methods then the cognitive load is not
high it's because it's very consistent
and consistency is very important about
consistency we make a lot of efforts to
have consistent names and it has so
inside image it has evolved with time
because for example now all organizing
filters are called annoys something and
also if you look at the signature of
functions then we try to have the same
name for the same kind of things like
the first argument will be called image
and keyword arguments will have the same
name if it's roughly the same concepts
like structuring elements still I'm
it's we also try to be consistent in the
internals of site it image so multiple
developers for the code like we had a
lot of discussions and the github
whether we should use indices for
dimensions ijk XYZ or playing well :
that's what we chose at the end of the
day because it's it's what you can
understand easily so a lot of things are
great I would say we say get image but
it's also good to learn by mistakes to
know what you do which isn't great and I
have an example of quite confusing
behavior that we have in circuit image
and it's related to data range and data
type because in in circuit image all the
functions suppose that if you have
integers images for example for you and
8 it's between 0 and 255 but if you have
float images you also have a fixed data
range which is between 0 and 1 and there
are some reasons behind this choice for
example choosing default parameters of
algorithms so that they will behave well
with if your image maximum is always the
same but it can be quite confusing for
users for example when you have an image
and so it's a float image and you
compute its histogram then you do a
median filter which transforms it into
an integer image then when you plot the
two histograms one will be between 0 and
255 and the other one will be between 0
and 1 so it's impossible to compare what
happened to the image will when
filtering so this is what we can
choosing and in fact a lot of our issues
and the github are related to this kind
of magic magics that we do with data
types and at the moment
it's hard to change because it changing
this behavior would break a lot of
things but then maybe we we should have
asked ourselves is really image maximum
a useful abstraction or useful enough so
that we impose a lot of things on our
users so that's one example where we
didn't go for the simpler option which
which would have been imposing nothing
and we pay it at a quite high price so
that was for the the the API
I would now I would like to speak about
really the learning process and the
documentation and the teaching part
because of course we all have this
romantic image of learning where we have
a great teacher who is teaching great
things and we just learn but we know
that when we're learning things we are
in Hawaii we don't have time and we
don't have time to go to classes maybe
we have the great by data tutorials but
we cannot attend all kinds of tutorials
so we need other ways to learn things
and a great way to learn things is of
course to have good documentation and
good documentation starts with
documenting the API of a package and
once again going backwards in time you
have to know that docstrings were in a
so estate ten years ago because course
numpy and sci-fi already existed and
this was the dark string so one nine so
it was difficult to learn a lot from
such dark strings and of course you all
know that dark strings are much better
now because parameters at the time are
described there are suggestions of other
functions you have meaningful and simple
examples to kick-start you to so that
you can start easily working with a
fashion so what happens we
in 2008 and now at the moment we didn't
have github and it was difficult for
people to contribute some help so there
was something called numpy documentation
martin was a tool which was more or less
a week he liked Wikipedia where you
could just edit the documentation and it
was how I started contributed to the
ecosystem because at the moment I didn't
feel very comfortable programming I was
not a hardcore geek and documentation
was really a an easy way to get started
giving back to the ecosystem and the
vampire documentation standard was also
introduced at the time so having
standards is very important and that's
why the you start a new package you
should really try to use an anti
documentation standard and it had a lot
of impact on the new empire inside by
ecosystem of course documentation got
better but it also increased the
standard for other packages and most
importantly it made people proud about
the docs and I think a lot of people
became contributors also because they
were proud about these tools and they
could speak about it with their
colleagues without them telling them oh
but it's complicated to use
documentation is not good so it's also
good to to have more contributors so
[Music]
document a documenting the API is
absolutely paramount you need to do that
but of course you will not read all the
dark strings of all functions you need
other things and one very useful things
is a graphical galleries of examples so
I think most of you know
matplotlib or scikit-learn graphical
galleries where at a glance you can see
different operations and click on it and
have the code and it's a bit like a menu
in a Chinese restaurant where you can
choose everything looks really appealing
and so you want to try everything that's
what a an example gallery should look
like and we also have one in-circuit
image so that if you click on one of
these thumbnails you have some
explanations and the code which
generated it and so it's actually an
umbrella project for all these galleries
so if you start a new project you don't
have to week out your gallery yourself
so who here knows about Sphinx gallery
few people but not many so you might
want to check it out and use it for your
own package because now it's very easy
to have a beautiful gallery from just a
few Python scripts and it will look
great so he just about Sphinx gallery so
you have the gallery but you can also
generate like small galleries in the API
so when you look at the documentation of
one function you will have the examples
using this function so it introduces
links between parts of the documentation
which is very important because people
will just follow one pass inside the
documentation but sometimes I get stuck
so they need more link to other parts of
the documentation and there are some
links also back to the API in the
gallery examples so trying to introduce
a lot of links between parts of the
documentation so galleries are great but
once again you don't want to look at all
the examples of the gallery when you
have a specific problems and I don't
know about you but for me I learn really
faster when I have very specific problem
which I don't know how to solve so it's
really a problem to even way of learning
and most of you must know the machine
learning flowchart which was done I
think by Andy Mueller so it's a bit like
game book I don't know if you know game
books where you have decisions to make
depending on your problem the kind of
data
how many features and so on and I think
this is very useful because it's
something that you can adapt to your
specific specific kind of problem so we
I think we should have more flow charts
like this and my dream would of course
to have something which wouldn't be a
PDF but something more interactive where
you could have your image and then these
questions would be asked I don't know by
the Jupiter notebook or something like
that so really an interactive way of
learning so we have made some steps tiny
steps but it's still important in this
direction for example we have this try
all threshold function where you give
your image and the output is a series of
images with results from a lot of
different filters so you can choose the
best for your application so it's a way
of learning first that all these filters
exist and comparing the difference for
your own images so this is also
something that we you should develop
more inside each image so for a bit of
science fiction I think that gamifying
learning is a really powerful way of
helping people to learn fast and I'm
using this you know what duolingo is for
learning languages so it's a quite funny
app which is asking you quizzes some
quizzes are very simple and it's a bit
addictive so you want to to do more and
sometimes it's more difficult and you
can just try to make sentences by just
clicking on words and you don't really
realize that you're learning it's like
you're playing
so it's a really powerful way of
learning and I don't know if we could
have this for numpy for example just
having people just clicking on words to
make good numpy instructions while they
were commuting in the tube or something
like that so I'm not sure it would be as
popular as duolingo but it might be
something was trying and we could also
do this for more complicated high level
stuff like image processing for example
image processing is often composed of
pipelines of different operations like
here for segmenting is very noisy image
I had to do first a denoising step and
then choosing markers from histograms
and then using a region propagation
segmentation algorithm so could we have
something where we can just combine
graphically in a game different image
processing operations and see the result
and it could be the image was it in-game
and people would learn how to do image
processing I don't know but once again
why not try towards more interactivity I
think we are already lucky to work work
in a very interactive environment which
we have ëifí Singh we have to Peter
which are very easy to use and have a
lot of interactivity like we can do
profiling we can do debugging and but
there are some goodies which can make
learning even more interactive for
example bender do you say bento binder
binder thank you
which can turn a link into an
interactive notebook so you don't even
need to have a Jupiter installed on your
notebook so we can convince a colleague
for example very easily and to introduce
Python and here is the link to the a
very big collection of circuit image
tutorials that's
you can just run and binder and it's now
possible to use binder for gallery
examples using strings gallery so going
back to strings galleries so we don't
have it yet in Psych it image but this
is an example from the Sphinx gallery
website where you have this lounge
binder badge and the example will run
then in the jupiter notebook on binder
so very easy way to interact with the
gallery example it takes a bit of time
because obviously binder needs to start
the container and so on but it's 20
seconds or less so it's it's still very
good for more interaction and learning
fast we can also use widgets I buy
widgets so for example in Sai kit image
we just have functions we don't have any
graphical interface or we have a viewer
but it's very experimental and using
effect on widgets you can for example
see the result of changing the threshold
of an image so it's also a way to test
very easily and fast the output of a
function so I just have to apologize
because this is something I copied and
pasted from the web yesterday I tried to
and I fight and I buy widgets on my
notebook but I couldn't make it working
so if so who's using III widgets here
some people okay so maybe someone will
help me after - to make I Phi which it's
a walk on my notebook but so for so in
order to explore data and to have an
interactive workflow
it can sometimes be problematic if you
have very large data because let's say
my tomography images there are 1000 cube
for just one image and sometimes I have
hundreds of them and I want to explore
the result of several filters several
operations that they will combine like
here for this tomography image I want to
segment three phases so I will do a
first threshold a median filter second
threshold so mathematical morphology and
each of these operations will take from
a few seconds to one minute and it's
very frustrating to start again the
whole pipeline every time you want to
change just one parameter in the filters
so this is where we have great tools
like job Lib with its memory function
because you can just cash the output of
some functions and then when you change
something in your program if other
variables were not changed then the
computations will not be done again so
it's a it's a weight first of course to
make things faster work faster but also
to increase interactivity and how the
easiness with which we will explore your
data and last but not least something
which is really great for learning is
going to a conferences two conferences
so congratulations to all of you I think
you found the best way of learning so
you learn at tutorials during talks
yesterday at the pub I was learning
about great ways of web squatting from
Alex for example so it's it's really a
way to discover new things don't stay in
your energy minimum meet new people
I've taken part in the organization of
USI by conferences for some years now so
Alex already said that next year it will
be in Toronto and so one output of this
USI by conferences is the Syfy lecture
notes website so who knows about the
cyber lecture notes not many people this
is interesting because it's an umbrella
project for a lot of tutorials you have
several weeks of tutorial so if you just
google type a lecture notes you will
find very easily and it has several
chapters one is for beginners so really
the core of scientific pison advanced
chapter is about learning more texts and
some package specific chapters as well
so it has been curated and enriched over
the years even if we were still looking
for people to help along maintaining and
contributing new chapters we would
really need a panda's chapter for
example for the beginners part so it's
it's also a way to make sure that people
can learn easily because when you give
tutorials or trainings to 20 people it
takes a lot of time and energy but when
I have a new person coming to my lab I
usually tell her oh just go to the Syfy
lecture notes and read the intro chapter
and so that after the person can follow
maybe directly she had an advanced
training and not spend too much time on
the into a part so one very last thing
before taking questions in my abstract I
said that the scientific writing
ecosystem is a great way to learn
programming fast but it's also a great
way to learn science and I think for
example scikit-learn has been a real
game-changer so that people would learn
machine learning so obviously
scikit-learn empowers people to
do some machine learning but it also
teaches and how machine learning works
and like this gallery example about
underfitting
versus overfitting it's really something
that you could find in a statistics book
or in a regular University class so
that's that's why scikit-learn is also a
great tool and we have the same in
circuit image like for example if you
want to learn what is pictured annoying
comparing different denoising filters is
a good way to get some intuition about
how these different filters works like
total variation wavelet denoising and so
on and in the documentation we also have
some quite mathematical explanation so
that you can of course just compare the
output of filters and use use them
without understanding really what's
going on but if you want to go further
there is food for thought and for for
learning more the mathematics background
and here is an example from again from
my research where we have this noisy
image and we can use several denoising
filters from very basic ones like the
median filter to the total variation
filter which gives the output is
posterized
image so images with constant gray
levels and you see how the histogram is
improved from the original image where
you have this big we say potato in
French without any Peaks to an Instagram
where you have two really well-defined
peaks and the total variation is really
the best filter so it's a kind of thing
that you can test quite easily with the
gallery examples and explanations and so
this will be my my final slide I would
say that so really the best way of
learning is contributing to open source
because it really boosts your learning
pace of four so for me starting
contributing to circuit image I learned
a lot about programming because when I
started I didn't know much about version
control about testing and so on so I
learned all this machinery of
maintaining a package but I learned also
a lot of image processing which was I
considered it as my strengths when I
joined the team but I learned so much
just talking with the other developers
like the discussions we have about
state-of-the-art algorithms on the
github like this snakes algorithm for
segmentation it told me really a lot of
things so I would say that being a
contributor is like the ultimate way of
learning about both programming and
science so I had a few slides about
performance and so on but it's more if
you have questions so to wrap up I think
when you're giving a keynote you have
this reaction Oh what should I be
talking about is it like important stuff
like where do we come from what are we
where are we going which is the title of
this beautiful Google painting so for me
the interest of this talk was more to
see what is great with our tools what
can we learn about them to create new
tools especially how to empower people
to learn fast our tools and how to use
them and maybe do we need also other
tools so I think I have we all know that
we've got great tools but can we make
them even more self learning making the
documentation more interactive for
example and for this we need new IDs but
also your contributions to the ecosystem
and you you don't have to be a
programming genius to be a contributor
even a co contributor I'm certainly not
a programming genius but if you just
have
these about what users think how they
learn and you can make very useful
contributions thank you
thank you there was another great
keynote on the topic of contributing to
open source just a reminder that we have
the bandhas print coming up after the
coffee break is Marc in the Roma not yet
maybe he's already there anyway the
under Sprint will be in the Mortimer
room at the end of the floor we have a
mic for the audience is there any
question time for one question or two
that's a question here please how do you
relate to the OpenCV community or if at
all in terms of I do you have any kind
of knowledge transfer between how the
libraries are kind of structured so
OpenCV OpenCV is computer vision
packaged and it's a really popular we
don't interact much I think some of our
developers are using OpenCV as well so
it makes sure that say we know what's
inside OpenCV but we don't walk with
develop development team of open CV
maybe we should actually I must say that
your question that because other
questions for me like oh should we work
with them we have slightly different
goals because we're not computer vision
package we we have some functions like
for feature extraction for simple
registration but we don't target exactly
the same users but I would say it's even
more
a reason to work together and to to see
if there are some possible interactions
the thing is that open CV is developed
mostly I think it's C++ yeah and so
python is it's mostly bindings in API
but I've made real progress is about
this when we started working on circuit
image it was not possible yet to have
numpy aways as arguments of open CV
Python bindings not now it works really
well but I don't know if they have a
strong fighting team but I should
definitely ask thank you for your
question yeah just before the break one
last announcement Gina from nan focus is
looking for a first-time attendee
somebody who is here for the first time
for an interview short interview the
question will be what motivates you to
be here so early in the morning look for
Gina next to the registration desk now
we have a coffee break and let's thank
Emanuel one more time
[Applause]